my
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
do
all right what the [ __ ] man yeah it
looks like people are falling over hold
on let me get some more ice
yeah he had to go at least i got to go
to the bathroom and get another drink
and [ __ ] like that
i don't know what the deal is we don't
every now and then like i have this
[ __ ] thing where it just
[ __ ] cuts out i don't know
but we're back again so hopefully
everybody
is over here now i don't know what the
[ __ ] i was talking about oh we were
talking about
new wave music weren't we where did he
go oh he went to get more ice
there you are
so what were you talking about before we
got all right
we were talking about warfare we were
talking about yeah we were talking about
like [ __ ]
teenage angst yeah
okay you know um
you guys have any other topics you guys
want us to discuss
questions or anything well yeah because
we just started a whole new stream so
it's like you got might as well like
[ __ ] put something
it might be some paranormal thank you
victor new laptop fun
[Laughter]
yeah it might be some questions on the
paranormal might be our connection
i'm just [ __ ] anything anything you
want to talk about we would talk about
answer any kind of questions
government trying to censor you guys oh
i don't think so i think it's just
honestly i think it's
my computer being a little old now cheap
and shitty
and because i don't i don't know that's
not that's not the app oh no this is the
new one
i honestly but it's cheap yeah i
honestly
most of the time like because we stream
five days a week
i almost never have a problem
every now and then when we do a longer
stream
it drops out i think that might be more
our connection than anything else
because
i don't know man i think our wi-fi is a
little turn the music down
okay i mean i can't hear it so
what brand of computer is it you know
what i don't even know
one more again one more again
[Music]
all right that should be good that
should be good because like i said it's
a whole
bunch of different songs so i don't know
some of them are louder than others
victor says i'm at work till 3 30 what's
streaming that's worth watching
just trying to give a uh just trying to
give a little bit of an ambient
tone to the program so you know yeah
i can't hear it so i don't know mark
says they love it
good okay cool yeah uh there's a bunch
of other [ __ ] i wanted to play but
man i'm so afraid of [ __ ] copyright
strikes i definitely downloaded i went
in
today and i downloaded three hours
of vaporwave that the dude that made it
was like this is copyright free you can
use it for whatever you want please
download it and use it so
i figured that was probably safe i mean
youtube
i don't know if you know this but
youtube has a whole channel
of music that you can use in your videos
but
there's so much stuff on there that it
was like really really hard for me
because it's like songs individual songs
and i was like i need like
an hour two three hours of [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying yeah i like to
have i like uh
vaporwave and just real [ __ ] generic
[ __ ]
because it takes me back to my [ __ ]
dead mall days i love dead mall videos
and there's just some something kind of
like relaxing music
in the back because it's like being in a
mall back in the day
and you're kind of just like oh [ __ ] it
it doesn't matter
dj maniac says the greatest trick rob
halford ever pulled was convincing
thousands of homophobes to dress like
leather daddies
yeah what's funny oh my god i love that
i love what's funny is that it wasn't a
trick
it was right there in the lyrics and
[ __ ] i could hear it back when i
could hear it even when i was a kid
in the 80s nobody knew [ __ ] which is
really funny there was a lot of [ __ ]
that i was like you know just listen to
[ __ ]
go on the sin after sin album and go
listen to [ __ ] raw deal that's about
[ __ ] going you know
being down on [ __ ] fire island
[ __ ] you know
one in one of those gay bars [ __ ] and
all these leather daddies coming at you
and [ __ ] you know sex that was like a
[ __ ] hurricane and
and then it was a raw deal and they're
too many yeah
too many of these damn dudes coming at
you you know what i mean and [ __ ]
they're all
cruel and [ __ ] because all this [ __ ]
bondage seemingly
yeah so so he's like uh
it's all there in the music it was just
uh
really is that was earl that was [ __ ]
70s i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] the raw deal [ __ ] song which
is a great song
it's a great song [ __ ] it's all over
youtube
a raw deal was rob halford coming out
it's just that
they did it a different way back then
they did a slick
which i kind of liked that because well
it's like we have plausible deniability
well it was more it was more like but he
says that
love knoweth no loss that is actually in
the [ __ ]
lyrics of that song that is absolutely
true love knoweth no law
and then um basically the style was
is that's none of your [ __ ] goddamn
business that it was a man's right that
he could do whatever he wants
now some people are like what the [ __ ]
you know everything everything today is
politicized and there's identity
politics
politics going on the khana had that
back then
but they just it manifested itself in a
different way
a lot of people you know history they're
constantly trying to erase history for
political
purposes uh anything that embarrasses
the lgbt
crowd they're going to want to [ __ ]
erase that anything that events
that are anything that embarrasses
anybody they're going to erase it
but to do that is [ __ ] destroying
[ __ ] truth
the sa which is the nazis
the nazi storm troopers that helped put
hitler into power
and the guys that started that whole
movement
were a men's rights movement
that was a euphemism for a gay movement
and it was
ernst rahm and all his guys in the sa
they were leather daddies
and hitler was in with him um
hitler was bisexual a lot of people
swear to that and that there was
something going on between hitler and
ernst rome long time before the nazi
party really was kind of like a
solid thing it wasn't until the night of
the long knives that hitler decided
to get rid of the sa and have them all
killed and arrested
and in place of the sa he chose the
german army the vermont
and uh he did that with the help of his
new ss
it the nazi party the early genesis of
it was
uh a men's rights movement well i feel
like there's a large thread in
authoritarianism in general yes of
homo eroticism but they don't want to
admit to it
so they always kind of like couch it in
different terms it depends on what it is
you're looking at they were
open with the essay was open about what
they were
they were open about it until it wasn't
okay to be open
about that well no until it started to
go mainstream
and hitler knew that the mainstream
german voter would not go along with
what the essay that's what i said unless
and and
the and this isn't a slight on gay
people it's not saying well gay people
are responsible for the [ __ ]
holocaust
it's just that well that is obvious
that's not what it means
the sa was maximum macho
women were beneath them that's how they
[ __ ] looked at it it was
well yeah it was it was so it was
misogynistic in the sense that in a
certain way
i mean well no in in every way because
it was like well males are
superior right yeah it was a male
supremacy movement sure
or it was the way to look at that it was
a man's right to do what they were doing
it was part
berlin and the whole german scene at
that time they were [ __ ] decades
ahead of the us in terms of [ __ ] i
guess you could say
sexual liberation i mean berlin was
[ __ ] wild
at that time but um they considered
themselves to be
spartan style warrior homosexuality
and they were open with it um
but like i said until it wasn't publicly
acceptable to be like that anymore
though because they just counted they
were on the night of the long knives
when they arrested them all
they were all partying in this [ __ ]
german hotel where they normally were
partying about they were also plotting
to
overthrow the government the german
government also because they didn't like
him
they started to realize that hitler
wasn't a share power with him okay
that hitler was favoring the ss so
uh hitler and his ss guys and his
[ __ ] policemen
gestapo policeman went to the hotel
where ernst rahm and all his boys were
[ __ ] partying
and they snuck in and then
burst into the doors and took pictures
of them all in bed together
and then they arrested them and they
used those [ __ ] pictures as leverage
and uh they sent them all to [ __ ] it
was a spandau prison or
one i think which prison was it i don't
remember them in prison i can't remember
they got a lot of guilty pleas out of a
lot of them and she went out and shot a
lot of them it
it wasn't for being gay though they were
shooting at them they shot them because
they were threatened
they were a threat to the ss and because
they were getting ready to overthrow the
government
um now the way [ __ ] evidently the way
ernst [ __ ] went down
they had earned strom in the cell and
the ss men [ __ ] showed up and
stuck a [ __ ] pistol through the
[ __ ] bars of the cell
and ernest goes go ahead shoot me shoot
me he's [ __ ] pulling it
pulling uh pulling his vest open his
shirt open and he goes
you tell the fuhrer i still love him and
that was his final words
see i tell the fuhrer i still love him
and he also said what did i do wrong it
was it was stuff like that
let me talk to him i can work this out
with him and they were getting rid of
bear down he because okay
okay if i can tell the fear i still love
him this is what i mean when i say that
like
i feel like women have been derided as
like [ __ ] for our whole entire life
for just like speaking up and doing [ __ ]
but men are way bigger [ __ ] men and
women have ever
like ever ever men i have never met a
woman
that was as big a [ __ ] as your average
man never
when it comes to men and power and
prestige yeah
they start [ __ ] infighting and they
[ __ ] the egos get in there
and they start trying to one-up
[ __ ] goodness
and they start trying to gang up and
then when they're then meanwhile
girls are just backing off going like
right
was described in old literature which
was accurate not the [ __ ] that's been
purged out now but
the old [ __ ] from back from the 70s the
50s 60s and 70s when they
went on all of them witnesses were still
alive and when when the story was still
fresh
ernest rum was was the word the
terminology they used
a predatory homosexual
if you if he liked you if you were a
young man and he liked you you weren't
going to be given a choice
so well that's not good a predatory
homosexual that's not good yeah so
that's what the
that's this is just it it is what it is
tila says dangerous [ __ ] there too
yeah yeah
indeed there male bitchery is way more
dangerous than female victory
yeah because i feel like women only get
labeled [ __ ] when we say
[ __ ] that men doesn't like you know what
i mean yeah
men don't like something and it's like
hey you [ __ ] shut up that was that's
like a way of dismissing
yeah hitler and his name but men are way
bigger [ __ ]
trust me yeah i've known many of them in
my almost 50 years
way bigger [ __ ]
they're saying that uh hitler had
strange tastes
hither and his niece yeah her name was
kelly
hitler um and gayle gayle [ __ ] shot
herself over
over adolf that was during the early
not worth it han hey evidently
okay first of all in german culture at
that time
going out with and mary and your cousin
was considered to be kind of like not
only acceptable but preferable
almost kind of like something out of
certain islamic countries
well i have to say that up until maybe
late victorian or maybe even the early
20s early 20th century
in the us england stuff marrying your
cousin was not really seen
that it wasn't that weird it wasn't like
incest but it is
after a few generations you can have a
lot of problems you can get away with a
couple times but you can't it's not
not on a regular basis uh but they
didn't really know that
then uh but it was kind of like uh in
germany in the early
cousin 1900s was considered to be like
super traditional
and it was kind of like strengthening
the family yeah you're keeping it all in
the fake blood yeah well you're keeping
the money all in
well then and the prestige is all kept
into it and all our good job yeah yes
and it was kind of like synonymous with
[ __ ] um
with aristocracy because the royals were
doing that too
well yeah that's obviously which is why
so many of them have no chins
right but uh gave a um
i saw i've seen pictures of her she was
a good-looking blonde
um now they've said that well she shot
herself because he was so abusive to her
and uh no uh most people say
from that time say that he shot
she shot herself because he wasn't
paying enough attention to her
and that shooting yourself in suicide
attempts were super
[ __ ] common edge lordy [ __ ] in the
early 1900's for german women
she shot herself with they were super
drama queens back then drama drama
people talking about snowflakes and
drama points nowadays
you guys had nothing yeah on
victorian or early 20th century they
would shoot themselves over
[ __ ] nothing yeah and she shot
herself in a place that wasn't [ __ ]
lethal really
from what i remember and it was with a
very small caliber pistol
so it was a true suicide attempt
i don't think she died maybe she did die
i don't remember but
she's like oh she didn't die right away
i just shut my ear off
but um there's a lot of misconceptions
and things that have been cleaned up
over the years to fit certain narratives
uh
like uh the fact that adolf hitler
actually um had lots of jewish friends
early on
and admired jewish people um
he was half jewish himself was he not he
believed no he believed he was one
quarter jewish
evidently he believed that his father
was half jewish
um so you're not and he was definitely
not the [ __ ] aryan ideal
none of the none of the high command
works well i feel like
all of this like white supremacy [ __ ]
it's always like people that
are like hey we're like the highlight of
white i'm like really
okay yeah a lot of that a lot of a lot
of this stuff you're telling yourself
that
a lot of this so-called white supremacy
stuff though around the time
it's it's uh you you're there it's blown
into modern
definitions of what was what and also
not exactly what they said things kind
of taken out
out of context like the whole thing of
the master race thing
that wasn't really there um
it what that came from was that they
were talking about that they were the
master race of europe that they were the
best
country and culture in europe that's
really where that came from
they actually were allies with
non-aryans with
you know the japanese and the italians
they had
well it's always kind of like we're
awesome but
we're going to align with whatever is
most convenient it was
it's it's hypocritical it was made no it
was just
made into [ __ ] what they were doing is
they were trying to be like the united
states
really uh and they were overcompensating
they were trying to
call themselves a superpower that they
were the best people in the world
and they were better than communists
because
the third right was a german
interpretation it was a german version
of communism
in the same way that juche ideal
which is is a north korean
interpretation of communism
which is very different you can take
communist
philosophy and interpret that [ __ ] any
way you
want to interpret it just like any other
religion which
it is a religion um
and even [ __ ] hair gobbles or dr dr
joseph
goebbels will tell he said that
politics was the ultimate form of
religion that it went
hero worship legend
mythologies philosophy
politics that that was the order of
evolution
and they didn't actually believe what
they believed
they propagated ideology to people
to unify them into a people to get
certain jobs done
in other words the high command of
germany didn't believe what it was
saying
okay here's a good idea here's a real
easy way to explain it
there's whole books on it there's full
videos on it
a good example was given to me is this
uh i saw an interview with this guy
when he was a little kid they were he
was listening to the [ __ ] nazi party
talk over the radio
and ellie kept hearing over and over
again was national socialism
he kept hearing that buzzword national
socialism german national socialism
national socialism
and he goes dead what what is
german national socialism and his dad
said
german national socialism is the will of
the fuhrer
and that's the easiest way to explain it
german national socialism was whatever
hitler wanted it to be
that's all it was well done that's all
it was
there wasn't really any ideology behind
it don't
yeah i mean i thought everybody knew
that no
a lot of people think that there's some
kind of a solid
ideology or that they believed in
certain things and that there was
basically it boils down to we're better
than everybody at the end
well that's what they told their people
that's what they told that's what they
told them
that's well kind of the long and short
of it
but everybody at that time everybody was
telling their people that
it was called right but a lot of people
know that that's [ __ ]
right no no okay
no no no the way the 40s were is the
four
in the four well i was in the lab back
then but i understood that the ideology
of the 40s was
it was the time of [ __ ] propaganda
well yeah i know
okay i know all right all right i don't
mean to mansplain to you
you are though yeah you're trying to
believe
you there wasn't much difference in
between what the germans were doing and
uh versus what the americans and and the
kind of were doing it's all about the
same thing
i know you told your people that they
were the best
because you had to raise the morale for
the world i know that's all well like i
said
i'm almost the same age as you i'm only
a couple years younger
so i remember when you were in school
you know they kind of it wasn't really
blatant
but they did kind of push this oh
americans are the best wherever
america's the best
so they really were doing that in school
and even back then i was just kind of
like
is this really i don't know man well
because i could see things from other
other people's point of view i'm like
well how did these people feel about
that because that's probably
not what they were feeling about it but
yeah but i was thinking that
when i was a kid so
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like it didn't i don't know it didn't
really work on me
when we were kids the only thing that
was close to the united states would
have been the soviet union and we were a
lot better off than the soviet union
true but so there was a certain element
of truth
into that back then but things that are
true or never
the things that you that are true are
usually temporary
and you you can't keep saying that
you're number one when you've
slipped to the position of number two
and like the thing you've slipped to the
position
and even when i was a kid like even when
i was 12 or 13 i'm like what is the
number one what does that even mean
what does that even mean well at that
time at that time you know the united
states was a [ __ ]
one of them was right but even back then
when i was 12 or 13 years old in
like the early to mid 80s i was like
wait what is
what does that even mean what does that
mean
it didn't mean anything to me well if i
had to explain that then you wouldn't
understand
oh well thank you i don't know i can't
understand you
yeah yeah i'm not excited i'm too stupid
to understand no i understand like i was
around at the same time as you were
i get that like i get that other people
yeah
bought into that but even when i was a
kid i was just kind of like what does
that even mean
you know what i mean yeah even back then
i was kind of like because i told you
before
i was ever since i was little i was i'm
kind of like
i'm not one of those people that it's
like
i don't know i i don't i don't buy into
like the whole like hey
this is what we're doing right now or
this is what the whole [ __ ] thing is
right now
not so much nowadays because everyone's
kind of doing their own thing but
back in the 70s and 80s you had to think
there was a there was a definite
mainstream like zeitgeist
everybody was doing this [ __ ] everyone
believes this [ __ ]
and i was just not on board with it
back then okay so all of the [ __ ] that
they were saying was like oh
the russians and all this other kind of
[ __ ] i was just kind of like yeah but
how do the people there feel how do they
how are they seeing this
how is it see how am i seeing it from
like other perspectives
you know what i'm saying so it's like it
was never something that was really
resonant for me i guess
yeah because i never really
i don't know i never really bought into
the whole hey we're number one and we're
the best at everything i never really
bought into that yeah
i don't know why i don't know why garum
townsend said that every country told
their people that they were the oh i
know i know and and i think i realized
that when i was a kid because i was like
well every country must be saying this
so it's like
obviously it can't be true for everybody
growing up in brazil though that was
kind of not true when you went
when i went to brazil they all wanted
out of brazil their greatest aspirations
was to go to the united states or europe
they wanted to they had to get the [ __ ]
out of brazil right but i'm just saying
in general
a lot of countries had that kind of
thing where i mean it wasn't just the us
like a lot of other countries had the
thing where
we're the best ever and like whatever
anybody says oh it's [ __ ] blah blah
so it's like i kind of
felt like when i was a kid i kind of saw
like well i was kind of like well
other countries are probably saying that
to their people too
the development but you go to a place
like guatemala they weren't saying that
right but i wasn't thinking about that i
was just thinking about like other
countries in the world and
i know that right i know a lot of them
were just [ __ ]
miserable wanted the hell out of there
right the worst one i can think of
in my lifetime when i was in brazil
their version of illegal aliens
that were like the ones that they were
trying to keep out
the ones that were like oh man we don't
want them over here we're
people from guatemala and guatemala was
just destitute at that time
and uh so it's just which and like i
said nothing
i never blamed those people either
because it's like look if i lived
somewhere that sucked really hard
i would want to get the [ __ ] out of
there too so i can't blame those people
for wanting to get the [ __ ] out of there
you had you had a lot of so i was kind
of like i don't know i i
i always found it really easy to like
put myself in
another person's mindset it's like if i
grew up in that country
what would i be thinking of right now
like would i be thinking my country was
awesome yes
yes or would i be thinking my country
sucks and i want to get out of there so
i
so i was i always found it really easy
to put myself in another person
me when i was in brazil going to the
school of graduate sao paulo which was a
[ __ ] an elite
international school the most
prideful in their country all right the
ones who are we are better than all of
y'all
[ __ ] all you [ __ ] we're the sweetest
were the sweetest students
they just thought everybody else was
garbage all right
so it's not they are told that they are
the best
i've heard sweden's pretty awesome but
you know so i'm not gonna say no
nobody's better than anybody
no no no in sweden you are superior i'm
just saying
at least back in the 80s in the 80s
sweet
in the 80s swedish kids thought they
were superior to everyone
so it's not an american thing this is
well no i that's when i that's
that's the point i'm trying to make is
that i never i realized that that was
that i was not the only person to be
taught that yeah i'm just saying that
like whatever country you grew up in
probably taught you the same exact thing
kinda
i mean i i realized that right the duty
to deal with the deal with sweden is
that they consider themselves to be kind
of like
like a like a uh would be a good way to
put it like a moral superpower
that they were morally superior to
everyone else all right
because they were they had achieved
perfect perfect equality
and a perfect balanced economy and that
they were all perfectly equal in other
words they thought they were kind of
like something out of logan's iran
and they were horrified by brazil
horrified by it
zach says norway has the highest
standard of living in the world yeah
yeah i've heard it was it's one of the
scandinavian countries i don't know it's
norway or not
um victor says if i won the lottery i'd
buy a ranch in new zealand
yeah i've heard new zealand's pretty
awesome i i have thought about going to
new zealand or australia you can't
afford to buy anything there though
yeah but i've heard new zealand and
australia is pretty cool
the thing that's appealing to me about
australia i don't like like the
flipped seasons thing that's going to
take me like a time
to get used to because i don't like that
our winter is your summer that's weird
because the southern hemisphere
but other than that i mean they speak
english australians are
kind of like americans in a way
but not exactly but all right business
we'll see you around bro
bye but enough that i it
that there would be something familiar
to hang on to but then there would be
like enough that would be
different that would be good you know
what i mean yeah
it is very far though and that's one
thing that kind of bums me out because
like my whole fam
family still lives here and it would be
like hard to visit them yeah
but i have thought about going to
australia before or like moving to
australia yeah
i think it'd be a nice place to go yeah
tina we should all be proud of our
countries but it's hard to you know
you really should be right that's what i
mean the thing about it is that it
doesn't really happen in reality but
yeah that's kind of the way it should be
i kind of feel like
where you're born that you don't choose
that
so it's not really something that
i don't know it yeah well it's hard for
me to like take pride in because it's
not something that you had control over
yeah but you can't really i understand
what you're talking about but that's not
that's not the way things actually
happen because well i know that
but i'm just saying i'm just talking
about my you can't you can't
you can't choose your parents either but
people will
start being yeah obviously they're very
proud of their parents
so what ends up happening is there's
that kind of this natural gravitation
towards like almost kind of like a blood
and soil [ __ ]
philosophy and it's every country i've
ever been to and lived to
like yeah i didn't choose to be
brazilian or i didn't choose to be from
uruguay
but i'm still the best and we're still
the best country because
this and this and this and this and this
and then they cast dispersion on other
countries
you guys are evil empires you guys have
this you guys have a bad
uh history uh there's a bunch of
different ways people can justify
feeling like they're in a better
position than other people and let's see
i think that in nature human nature to
okay it's human nature technologies all
play on human natures that's why this is
it's human nature to if you are insecure
with your own
accomplishments if you're like insecure
about your own background whatever
it's very human to denigrate
other people's accomplishments other
people's backgrounds
to make yourself feel better
so if you have no accomplishments
if you have nothing to your name then
it's very easy to say well i'm from here
and we're the best
so you guys all suck i don't have to do
anything
myself it's easy yeah
it's easy yeah that's not really what
we're talking about though um it is
though because it's easy to say that
like that's like the easiest thing to
say i'm just from here i'm like i'm from
this country so we're just better and i
don't have to do anything but you when
you go to other countries and you
actually meet these people
they're not people that don't have
anything to their names a lot of times
they're rich people
a lot of times they're very educated
people so you can't just go well this
person doesn't have a pot to piss in and
they're trying to
overcompensate actually quite the
opposite you meet a poor brazilian
they're very humble
you meet a rich educated person an
educated brazilian no they're pretty
arrogant
all right and they'll come up with
they'll come up well rich people in
general
are arrogant well okay but they'll come
up with a lot of looking very in
intelligent reasons why brazil is better
than
the united states or that brazil is
better than russia or that
it is just part of the way people are
and i don't cast aspersions on them
i'm not here preaching and telling other
people do it how to live their lives
i just understand that that this is the
way people are
sometimes they have to kind of like
mitigate around it
there's other diplomatic ways to
negotiate it just because a person's
like that
doesn't mean they're the enemy it
doesn't mean that they're bad people
it also doesn't necessarily mean that
they're wrong a lot of times you can
still charm a person like that
well i would never here's the thing i
would never
cast aspersions like look a person
that's from anywhere
i'm not gonna cast aspersions on anyone
that is like
but i do kind of like if the only thing
that you have to your name
is hey i'm from this place so that makes
me better
or i was born you know i was born rich
that makes me better
that's the only thing that kind of like
but like look if you have a lot of like
if you did a lot of [ __ ] yourself your
accomplishments
i don't give a [ __ ] where you're from
then
you just own that [ __ ] yeah everybody
just like [ __ ]
be yourself man
garcia says he's gonna he's writing the
ouija cat movie right now
see i would watch that yeah the ouija
cat move
i could i pictured in my head when he
said that like earlier
i was picturing pookie with a planchette
and she had like both her little i call
him kitten mittens
so her little kitten mittens are on the
[ __ ] planchet
and she's like contact and spirits if i
could get her to
do that for a long time which she
probably wouldn't
but you know that's what i was imagining
but i'm just saying
how much you you want another drink or
you think you've had enough
um should i have another one i don't
know you sound pretty [ __ ] loaded to
me well i know
but you sound pretty how long is how
long has this stream been going on
well 34 minutes but our last one
was like what two hours three hours i
don't remember
because it [ __ ] dropped us yeah
this uh these are fun though what's that
these are fun yeah but let's get on more
fun uh let's get on a more fun topic
though
this isn't fun no this is [ __ ]
divisive
i'm having fun i'm having
this is divisive i can't i can't like
[ __ ] says i'm in new zealand i would
never
move to the united states yeah because
we don't have social life
well that was a lot of reason why my
ex-husband
was uh um reluctant to move here and
like i can understand that because
[ __ ] i don't know if you guys know i
haven't had health insurance since
2016. yeah so
i get sick i'm hosed yeah there's
no actually i'm hosed actually if you
just go to the emergency room
[ __ ] they'll still send you a bill
they'll send you a bill but you know
what you do you don't know that
you don't have to well i know but it's
it's still
that's still a credit strike you know
that right yeah but
um and i already have a foreclosure on
my credit
that that house still now that house is
gonna be gone
i know but it's still on my no
it wasn't that long ago it's only seven
years
yeah but it hasn't been done oh it's
been longer than seven years no it
hasn't it hasn't
nope i wouldn't worry about that that's
still on my [ __ ] that was during the
2008 [ __ ]
here's what you guys i don't know if you
guys know okay now she's going to tell
you her entire financial history
all her all her author give me a drink
here we go so you guys
i was married to a british dude i'm old
i told you
so i was married to a british dude we
were married for
15 years i think something like that
so we divorced in 2009
2010 something like that so we had a
house we had bought a house
in daytona and um
so at that point i was kind of like i
was just kind of like getting
i was like look just have the house um
i'm going
so i moved to orlando i left him
and perhaps many people will tell me i'm
stupid i left him the house i left him
the car that i had mostly paid for
it's like just take it i just i want out
of here
so i leave
it's fine he pays the rent on the house
for a while
and then after about i don't even
remember how long it was six months a
year or something like that
he's like well i'm going back to the uk
because like i said he's british
so at this point the house
still has 50
40 000 remaining on the mortgage
and the car is still in my name
and you know what not
so he leaves the house there's a bunch
of [ __ ] in there i don't even like
[ __ ] know
he leaves the car at the airport and he
goes back to the uk
me and tom go and pick up the car and
i'm like well
it's a nicer car than what i have now
but i tell him like look the car i have
now
which is like an old [ __ ] what is it
it's a ford [ __ ]
it's for taurus it's a four it's an old
four taurus yeah that's okay that would
repaint that [ __ ]
it it's old it's rusty i'm like look but
it's starting
i got drunk one time and jumped up on
the [ __ ] hood and walked on the
[ __ ] roof of the car you did
i was [ __ ] joking with singing and
dance i crushed the [ __ ] roof in i
popped it back out later but it was
[ __ ] funny
it's fine and because it kind of bent it
popped a little bit of the paint off and
it started to rust but i think maybe the
sun might have done that anyway because
it happened on the trunk too
on the rear on the rear i don't think
that was you i think that was the sun
but i i bought it because i bought that
exact paint the other day
so i'm just going to sand that [ __ ] down
re-spray that because here's the thing
as long as we've been living in this
house which is a little
nine or ten years um i can't pull the
car into the garage because
you have too much [ __ ] in there that's
my gyms in there [ __ ]
i know so i have to park the car in the
driveway
this is florida so the sun just [ __ ]
baby it'll hurt the car in the driveway
it'll just bake
everything off it it will bake white
paint off of a car
it will bake my car is silver it's
silver and it'll bake silver paint off a
car it's only a matter of time
my car's a 2004 i don't give a [ __ ] it's
better it's old
i got it for like what fourteen hundred
dollars
not even no no not even i saw i saw that
it was 1200 and then
no it was less i think it was less it
was 1200
and then we paid 500 to fix it it had a
good body and a good interior it had
problems with the [ __ ] with some of
the ignition problems
it [ __ ] had a roach infestation in
the damn car
because it was a company car and they
left a [ __ ] sack of garbage in the
back of it
that's right we had to do bug bombs you
had to bug bomb the [ __ ] car
and i think in the car it was full of
room all the tires were shot
but it was all something i could fix it
was the roach
infested yeah and the motorized florida
and the [ __ ] motor was low mileage
it was it was it was i was like man i
think we paid 800 for that and then put
another
it wasn't 800 it was i don't think so i
think it was no it was
it was 1400. well no i paid it was 1400.
yeah but that was after we got all those
times
it was 1400. and then when we put the
tires the new battery
all that kind of [ __ ] it was more like
2000 once it was done it looked brand
new
i paid 1400 yeah that car looked brand
new because he was asking
1800 yeah and i talked him down to 1400
because i had cash
talking about a damn car on the
livestream
this is a new topic okay livestream all
right and they don't seem to be asking
any questions about any [ __ ]
paranormal thing or [ __ ] nothing
they're just like [ __ ]
kayla says roaches in a car roach is in
the damn car
oh my god german cockroaches it was
infested you didn't even know
the car yeah was infested infested with
[ __ ]
invested that was one of the reasons why
see it look the car
looked brand new all right it looked
like it's a good car it's still
running it's still running and it had
been sitting behind a damn gas station
it was his company it was a company car
and he didn't use it anymore
he would have been like sitting in his
driveway for a long time yeah
and then he's like look i gotta sell it
he sold it
i bought it he was um selling it for i
think it was
1800 to 2 000. i talked him down to 1400
because that's what i had in cash i'm
like
dude i have 1400 cash right now i will
give you 1400 in cash right now
if you sell this car we bought the car
we drove it away from his house and we
drove
maybe a mile or two and then the battery
died yeah it did better
and then we had to stop at a gas station
and buy jumper cables because i didn't
have any
yeah and restart the event and then we
had to buy a new battery
also we had to buy a new battery we had
to buy new tires
but it was only 1400 so and it's still
running about six about six hundred
dollars later in you know what i mean it
took
put about a six hundred dollars on top
of it just like a solid car it's been
running really
it has a vacuum leak somewhere i haven't
been able to find it i've had it forever
but it hasn't
got i think it's in the gas tank you
know where the gas tank it's one of
those cars where
it's like when it's cold and i'm talking
about cold as in
under 65 degrees yeah fahrenheit
um when you stop at a satellite it'll go
like
it's called stumbling yeah it'll stumble
but
that's because there's a vacuum like
somewhere it's pretty solid otherwise
never been able to find it pretty smoked
out i think it's in the gas tank and i
don't want to drop the gas tank see
yeah so [ __ ] it it's not really worth it
it's not it's old
it's a 2004 i mean but it has like we
don't
have to drive anymore and i have to say
i was actually going to all right so
graham says why didn't you buy a [ __ ]
battery at the gas station because
there was no batteries at the gas
station the gas stations
you see he's in he's he's gas stations
the united states sell gas
and food they don't sell like a bag the
batteries are all at the [ __ ] places
like autozone and stuff so you have to
go to
there's no such thing as a service
station anymore like you used to be able
to go to a gas station they also we buy
oils and work on [ __ ] let me finish what
i'm saying and work on
you can't go there's no service stations
anymore gone
if you want a car worked on you have to
go to a [ __ ]
uh a dealer that'll work on that
or like a private mechanics shop
it's [ __ ] the whole thing's [ __ ]
changed because cars are now kind of
like a disposable item when they start
to get old you just [ __ ] traded it in
on a new one
that's what they're doing well so the
whole [ __ ]
the whole um culture of uh
fixing your own car it's almost kind of
like dead now which is weird because i
i fix all my [ __ ] well what happened was
that
i bought the car look i had a nissan
prior and then i got in an accident
oh no smog checks in florida no um
i got an accident and like a bad
accident the car was totaled in um
when was that 2000 uh
15 i think i know you guys drinking out
there or what
we are yeah it vitamin too because i was
still
um working because it was on my way to
work
i got in a car accident on my way to
work and i know i'm a tolerant man
my nissan was um total
so that got totaled and then i got my
insurance money
and then i bought another car because i
was like look i'm just gonna buy like
some cheap [ __ ] that that i can just
drive around
in so i bought this fort taurus i bought
a ford taurus because he told me
buy it for a tourist because i can work
on those yeah
that's what he told me he's like buy one
of those buy an old one
i know how all the engine works and it's
like i can fix it if it breaks so i just
bought one of those there's [ __ ] two
one i could [ __ ] work on a taurus
but what's even better man it's a crown
victoria
or a [ __ ] mercury grand marquis the
old ones like the cop cars
[ __ ] i know that car inside and out
that's what i do so that's why i that's
why we bought
crown victoria man that's the [ __ ]
that's your that's your taxi and your
what's it
that's your taxi that's your [ __ ] cop
car i just saw it
with that crap was it that funny it was
all sticking up sticking up okay
hold on put a hat on
the best [ __ ] car in the world all
right
i'm saying this with all honesty all
right
best car in the world's crown victoria
ford crown victoria
that's why they're cop cars that's why
that's why
all your taxis are crown vics they're
easy to work on
parts of [ __ ] like i said i just want
a car strong
that is wrong that i don't have to worry
about
yeah because i'm a very no [ __ ] kind
of person you could take a [ __ ] crown
vic you could buy a 800
jalopy [ __ ] crown vic and for another
eight hundred dollars [ __ ] have a
decent car
scott says it's wake time time nah [ __ ]
the wigs
later i'm not that drunk yet the [ __ ]
um
[Laughter]
just that's a caveman car the [ __ ]
crown
crown victoria it's a [ __ ] great car
engine rebuilds [ __ ] easy just
everything just that's the last
of the american car that you can work on
as far as i know yeah
yeah easy well that's why he told me he
was like well buy
some kind of ford because i can work on
it
i can fix it if it breaks and it'll be
free
you get 250 000 on one more and you'll
get all so
we went around and looked around we
found this dude that was selling this
ford taurus
and it had been his company car
and so there wasn't a [ __ ] ton of miles
on it it was not
actually in fairly good shape but
one thing was that he had left one thing
he had left a bag of garbage in his
trunk
for i'm not really sure how long
and also the car was infested with
cockroaches yeah
german cockroaches it ran fine yeah
um other than the battery dying like
literally 15 minutes after we left the
dude's house
yeah and we had to stop at a gas station
get jumper cables then we had to go
to our house and then go to autozone and
get a battery
like the next day but the car was
infected with roaches
so we had to bug bomb
the car yeah which
i don't know like i was afraid the whole
car would explode
because i thought like those bug bomb
things i've done about like
up apartments and [ __ ] like that said an
apartment that was like [ __ ]
it's florida you guys at an apartment
that was like infested with cockroaches
it wasn't i wasn't dirty
but like my neighbors were so
yeah the dude the dude [ __ ] was gonna
throw his garbage out and he put it in a
trunk
and then he forgot about it evidently
and it sat in there for a [ __ ] about
a month
bacon in the florida sun and all the
cockroaches infested the damn car
and i sat in the car to drive it and
[ __ ] saw a cockroach [ __ ] come out
of the damn they were just like crawling
on the [ __ ] yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on here and he's
going like oh i know what it is and he
went out there and [ __ ] the trunk and
papa truck and goes i have garbage in
here and he [ __ ] threw it out and the
cockroach is running everywhere
and i said man [ __ ] i said i said
dude that's a couple hundred dollars off
right there he's like yeah yeah
you should not buy cars from dudes
because
they apparently completely forget when
they have put an entire bag of garbage
in their trunk and have forgotten about
it
for several months i feel like that's
not something a chick would do
yeah he was at work though i guess throw
that [ __ ] away
get your [ __ ] okay let's talk about two
more roaches is that a real thing yeah
it's a real thing oh my
god you guys okay yeah so
i am not um okay
i'm not like i like i said i'm in horror
movies i love all that [ __ ] i am not
scared of spiders worms
nothing like that i'm not scared of bugs
florida cockroaches gross me the [ __ ]
out
tell them jenny and i'm not really sure
well i think it's because
i think it's because when i was a kid
i grew up largely in
like i spent a lot of time at my
grandmother's house
and my grandmother's house was built in
1958
we didn't have central air she just had
you know the window unit which was in
kind of the dining area
so if you had bedrooms in the back of
the house like the
air conditioning to really get back
there so
it was a concrete house but you still
got
cockroaches in there she had some
palmetto trees
in the yard which are um
nests for the palmetto bugs
so we got a lot of [ __ ] a lot of the
palmetto bugs and roaches
back in the day so it was i wouldn't say
it was infested
but it wasn't uncommon
so every now and then i would be
sleeping at my grandmother's house
and you'd wake up in the mallet and you
would hear
[Music]
you would hear that kind of noise
and that was like a roach climbing up
your wall
and you knew what that sounded it was
inside the house
yes and you would wake up in the middle
of the night and you'd be like
i had to leave that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where
is it
and then like you turn you turn the
light on you be like where
and you couldn't see it and then like
you'd be
anxious because you'd be like it's in
here somewhere shitty's acting it out
no i'm just saying it you can't see it
but it's in there
look this is what it's in there this is
what i did and it's going to fly
it's going to fly that's what i did i
took two of them [ __ ]
bug bombs i knocked the [ __ ] back
seat down
that way i connected the [ __ ] trunk
and the [ __ ]
and the uh the cabin all right i took
those
i put a bug bomb in the trunk and a bug
bomb in the [ __ ] front seat
[ __ ] bomb that [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
windows uh gassed them all right
[ __ ] came back next day wasn't it the
next day
yeah and i had a damn gas-powered
[ __ ] leaf blower
i threw the things out and i was [ __ ]
and i have to tell you that a couple
days
afterwards like i came out to drive the
car to work and like outside the car
there were some dead workers outside the
outside of the car because they're
hiding up in all the cracks inside the
superstructure and [ __ ]
i took the damn leaf blower was [ __ ]
blowing it down through all the [ __ ]
vents and [ __ ] in the dashboard
i [ __ ] took all the [ __ ] carpeting
out took all the upholstery out
i left it in there to poison it but man
that [ __ ]
and it was uh it was those expensive bug
bombs i forgot the name of that [ __ ]
and that smell is still in there a
little bit it is a little bit i can walk
in there and go
still smell that butter that was [ __ ]
years and years ago
never had a problem roses after that
never
it did kill like like i said we did it
um
we put the bug bomb in the cup holder
yeah and we did that and then like we
let that
kind of do and then like all the we
scooped up all the dead brooches that
were
like on the driveway and like on the
[ __ ] whatever yeah
and then we did it again yeah and then
once all that [ __ ] was out of there i
[ __ ] took
um i took a brush and some water and
some
and um some uh like uh
laundry detergent and i washed all the
interior washed all the
carpeting and all the [ __ ] um
upholstery
did all that and then uh washed
everything down
actually i took a hose to the inside of
the car too didn't i you did you was
blasting it out there with a [ __ ]
pressure washer i think
and then it was a pressure washer would
just bring the hose yep because i told
you i was just like dude
i'm not driving in that [ __ ] if i feel
like some roaches are gonna climb when
it was done it was it looked like a new
car
it did uh it you could smell a little
bit of that [ __ ] poison but it wasn't
that bad
it's dirty now but that's just like yeah
that's that's just where you freaking
walk that's just regular [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] what else you guys what else you
guys no i was going to say that because
you got more [ __ ] to talk about roaches
no
yeah go ahead and tell them more about
roaches jenny
well no i told you back in the day
because like i said
my grandparents house where i grew up
built in 1958 one of those concrete
black houses
didn't have central air only had a
window unit
in the dryer in the dining room so
in the back bedrooms like it was
it wasn't infested with roaches but it
wasn't like a big shock to see them
because they would just come in
so yeah they're [ __ ] good i remember
what going pressure washing the interior
hell yeah i pressure wash the interior
yeah we did
[ __ ] hit that [ __ ] like a man i was
[ __ ] blasting that [ __ ] up
just i was trying to get it yeah we just
[ __ ] just trying to get every
and it was like please yes the summer
was hot as hell
and uh rolled all the windows up just
left them cracked
and for like three days the inside of
that [ __ ] windows were all just
[ __ ]
fogged up a [ __ ] mist and you walk in
there
because i told him like [ __ ] i'm not
driving that and yeah
yeah i want all it eventually all dried
out there but it took a couple days
it took a couple of days of florida heat
to dry out the inside of that car
because like i said i grew up here so
i'm like i'm not a fan
of because look like i said the house i
grew up in
was built in the 50s and it didn't have
central air
it didn't have it had big gaps under the
doors
so roaches had no problem going like oh
can i come in here
well thank you i'm coming in here so we
had that whole thing
so like i said every i was very used to
like waking up in the light and hearing
like hearing some like [ __ ] roach
like crawling up the wall in the night
marcos says that his car comes with an
emergency pee bottle
okay you can reach down there that's so
gross but do you throw the bottle out
or do you well you better or do you put
it back in the cup holder i'm like so
jealous of like dudes that can just like
because you have that whole you have a
whole hose system
yeah that you can put in a bottle yeah
it's much harder for girls
much harder but yeah so um yeah so
i remember very clearly i had a bedroom
in the back of my grandparents house
and there was you know it was a big
bedroom and it was like a little half
bathroom
and there was a big closet and
i very very distinctly remember
going in my closet i guess it was kind
of a walk-in closet not that big
and i put on a shirt that had like a
you know like a pocket right here like a
breast pocket
and i put the shirt on and out of the
breast pocket
came a huge cockroach well i had the
shirt on
and i lost my [ __ ]
i lost my [ __ ] so this is kind of like
and
i've also kind of like put on a shoe
in a car like i think it was my mom's
car i put on a shoe in my mom's car and
a
big huge cockroach crawled across my
foot
so i'm not a big fan of cockroaches
as a rule um
so like i said i can see how like people
that
you guys if you don't live in florida
like the concourses they're so big
and they fly some of them fly
yeah okay do you guys uh have any
questions is there anything else you
guys want to talk about
tila says ladies are sml we can't do the
bottle thing yeah
i know yeah i just can't
it's too hard man it's you can't like i
said i don't have a hose
so
yeah i don't i don't remember ever wait
what the she-wee is the answer yeah
[Laughter]
all right then we've been streaming for
uh probably close to four hours it's
probably about time to shut this down
um if there's if there's nothing else
that you guys want to talk about just
wanted to thank you for showing up
tonight
but uh i think that me and jenny
probably had enough
drinking for tonight wait it's only 8
30.
oh we stopped again oh we [ __ ] oh
we froze up again yeah yeah it froze up
i don't know maybe the audio is still
going is the audio still going people
is it i don't know i can't do anything
okay i can't do anything
it froze people
yeah okay
all right are you guys still seeing the
[ __ ] or yeah this we're probably back on
your scene say no you're here they still
hear us
okay yeah but there's like a lag yeah
there's the they're
giving me like 5-10 seconds there's a
lot of lag in the
uh it froze again it froze again yeah
okay guys well we'll see you guys later
we're gonna shut it down we're gonna
have problems um we're having problems
with the stream
and um we'll be back saturday
yeah we guys will be back saturday yes
see you bye-bye
like share subscribe like share
subscribe do all that all right
so [ __ ] will it even shut off
i don't know okay we'll find out we'll
find out we'll find out